AND SECURITY.
AND THAT MISSION GOES ON.
♪ ♪
>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
IT TURNS OUT THE DOJ FAILED TO
DICTATE THE FINAL RESULT OF THE
2,018 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, BUT
A YEAR AND A HALF INTO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT STILL SEEMS TO AT
TIMES BE OPERATING AS A SHADOW
GOVERNMENT, A PLACE THAT
CONSIDERS ITSELF BEYOND THE
REACH OF NORMAL OVERSIGHT.
BACK IN THE REAL WORLD, CONGRESS
HAS THE EXPLICIT CONSTITUTIONAL
POWER TO OVERSEE THE FBI AND ALL
OTHER EXECUTIVE AGENCIES, LESS
WEIGHT SUPPOSED TO WORK.
APPARENTLY THAT FACT INFURIATES
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
ROSENSTEIN.
EARLIER THIS YEAR IN JANUARY,
ROSENSTEIN THREATENED TO APPEAL
THE EMAIL SENT ON STAFFERS
BECAUSE OF HER BEING TOO
AGGRESSIVE.
THE MESSAGE FROM ROSENSTEIN,
BACK OFF.
YOU DON'T INVESTIGATE US, WE
WILL INVESTIGATE YOU.
FOX'S CHIEF CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE BROKE THAT
STORY AND SHE HAS MORE ON IT
TONIGHT.
SPEAK OF THE EMAILS WRITTEN ON
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTS FORMERLY
DOCUMENTED THE JANUARY MEETING
FOR THE HOUSE OFFICE OF
GENERAL COUNSEL.
THE TOUGH LAWYER FOR PROTECTING
CONGRESS.
FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY,
THEIR SENIOR ADVISORS AS WELL AS
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES AND HIS
SENIOR STAFF.
IT CAME AT THE HEIGHT OF ALLEGED
GOVERNMENT SURVEILLANCE USAGE
VIEWED AT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
TODAY THEY RESPONDED TO
ALLEGATIONS AND ROB ROSENSTEIN
THREATENED TO SUBPOENA RECORDS
AND TURN THE TABLES ON
REPUBLICAN-LED HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
OVER THE RUSSIA CASE.
>> IT IS DEEPLY CONCERNING THEM
INSTEAD OF HAVING A COOPERATIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS AGENCY,
RESPECTFUL OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CONGRESS HAVING ACCESS TO
DOCUMENTS REGARDING MATTERS THAT
THEY ARE INVESTIGATING, THAT
THEY HAVE OUT OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR, THIS IS NOT
THE WAY TO CONDUCT THAT.
SPEAK OUT THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT STRONGLY DISPUTE THE
CHARACTERIZATION
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
TOLD FOX NEWS THAT ROSENSTEIN
NEVER THREATENED ANYONE WITH A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE DEMOCRAT
TOOK AIM AT GERMAN NUNEZ WHO
STOPPED FOR A DOCUMENT OF
INCIDENT.
>> I KNOW THE REPUTATION OF ROB
ROSENSTEIN AND THAT IS ONE OF
IMPECCABLE CHARACTER.
AND I KNOW THE REPUTATION OF IT
DEVIN NUNES, AND THAT IS ONE OF
MISLEADING, OBSTRUCTING,
ATTEMPTING TO INTERVENE IN AN
INVESTIGATION.
>> TODAY, CHAIRMAN INEZ AND
MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE SIGN THIS
LETTER TO ROB ROSENSTEIN
REJECTING ANOTHER BRIEFING BY
THE FBI SAYING, ANYTHING SHORT
OF PROVIDING THE RECORDS THAT
ARE UNDER SUBPOENA IN THEIR
OPENING AND IS AN OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
TUCKER?
BREAKING THAT STORY IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
ROD ROSENSTEIN'S RECENT BEHAVIOR
IS NOT THE ONLY EXAMPLE OF THE
DOJ APPARENTLY VIEWING ITSELF AS
BEYOND BEYOND NORMAL OVERSIGHT.
MONTHS AGO, WE DISCOVERED THAT
FBI AGENTS PETER STRZOK AND
OTHER PAGE WERE USING THEIR
PERSONAL VIEWS INTRUDING ON
THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT DUTIES.
HOW FAR WILL THAT GO INTO WELLS
MAY BE INVOLVED?
THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW
THAT BUT WE DON'T BECAUSE THE
DOJ KEEPS TRYING TO CENSOR THE
TEXT MESSAGES BEFORE RELISTING
THEM.
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE.
IN A SEPTEMBER 2015 TEXT, HE
MAINTAINS ABOUT THE HANDLING OF
A CASE BUT THE EXACT ROUTE
COMPLAINT WAS HER EXACT STOMACH
REJECTED.
THANKS TO WORK BY SENATOR RON
JOHNSON'S OFFICE, WE KNOW THAT
HE WANTED TO QUOTE BARGAIN AWAY
EVERYTHING AND THAT IT HAD A
QUOTE STOCKHOLM SYNDROME.
AND HOW THEY DID EVERYTHING THEY
COULD TO AVOID BRINGING CHARGES
AGAINST ANY OF CLINTON'S TEAM.
WHAT IS CLEAR, IS THAT NOTHING
HE SAID WAS A SECURITY THREAT
THAT WOULD REQUIRE A REDUCTION
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE COUNTRY.
THE DOJ WAS JUST TRYING TO COVER
ITSELF FROM KEEPING THE PUBLIC
FROM LEARNING THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON, IS NOT A
DEFENSE?
PROFESSOR, IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
QUESTION.
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ALLOWED TO REDACT INFORMATION
SOLELY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PROTECTING ITS ON REPUTATION?
>> IT IS NOT, EVEN THOUGH IT HAS
A LONG HISTORY OF DOING SO, NOT
JUST IN CONGRESS BUT IN THE
WHAT'S REALLY FUNNY IS, THEY
WILL CHARGE SOMEONE WHO GIVES
THE MISLEADING INFORMATION, BUT
THEY WILL TELL CONGRESS THAT
THEY REJECTED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION THAT PROVES ENTIRELY
UNCLASSIFIED.
THERE IS THIS SENSE OF ACTING
WITHOUT HER IMPUNITY, WHEN YOU
REDACT THESE TYPES OF DOCUMENTS.
AND THAT MATERIAL IS CLASSIFIED
UNDER ANY DEFINITION.
THEY CAN DISAGREE WITH CHAIRMAN
NUNEZ, THEY CAN DISAGREE WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE, BUT THEY SHOULD
ALL AGREE ON THE FACT THAT THIS
IS AN IMPROPER USE OF REDUCTION.
>> Tucker: AND IT'S BEEN GOING
ON YOU SET FOR QUITE SOME TIME,
SO THIS IS BASICALLY THE
STATUS QUO, NOT A NEW WAY OF
DOING BUSINESS?
>> UNFORTUNATELY IT IS.
I'VE BEEN COUNSELING SECURITY
CASES AGAINST THE GOVERNMENT,
AND I HAVE REDACTED TO THE
COURTS THAT IT'S CLEARLY NOT
CLASSIFIED.
AND, NOBODY DISPUTES THAT ROB
ROSENSTEIN WENT OVER TO THE
CONGRESS AND THREATENED TO
SUBPOENA THE PERSONAL
COMMUNICATIONS OF MEMBERS THERE.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT AND WHAT IS ASKED SUGGEST
ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE DOJ AND THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE?
THESE COMMITTEES HAVE NOT HAD A
ROBUST OVERSIGHT RECORD.
THEY OFTEN ROLL OVER.
THIS IS SOMETHING NEW, AND
FRANKLY, THOSE OF US WHO WANTED
MORE OVERSIGHT HAVE WELCOMED THE
LAST YEAR.
FINALLY YOU HAVE A COMMITTEE
SAYING, WAIT.
AND THREATENING WEATHER IT'S
CRIMINAL OR CIVIL, STAFFERS OR
MEMBERS, IT'S CLEARLY
INAPPROPRIATE.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT ROSENSTEIN
MAY HAVE FELT HE WAS BEING
MISTREATED, BUT THAT DOESN'T
MATTER.
YOU HAVE TO GET OVER IT.
CONGRESS CREATED THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, THIS ISN'T PERSONAL.
IT IS OVERSIGHT BUSINESS.
SO NO MATTER HOW AGGRIEVED YOU
MAY BE, YOU CANNOT SPEAK TO AN
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND THREATEN
THOSE STAFFERS WITH TAKING
SOMETHING LIKE SUBPOENAS TO
THEIR DOORSTEP.
>> Tucker: CONGRESS DOES HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THE EXECUTIVE
AGENCIES, INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, CORRECT?
I MEAN, YOU WATCH THE OTHER
CHANNELS AND WOULD THINK THAT
WAS SOMETHING THAT THE
RIGHT-WINGERS MADE UP LAST WEEK.
BUT THAT'S A CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLE, AM I RIGHT?
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND